[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
we've all heard about the great variety
of sea life swimming in our oceans so
the following
stat may surprise you according to the
national ocean service
more than 90 percent of ocean species
have yet to be classified
so it's quite an event when something
brand new is brought to the surface
as recently happened in the waters off
japan from tokyo lucy kraft shows us
what they found back in 2016
an expedition off central japan yielded
an astonishing discovery
specially made fishing lines long enough
to reach the ocean floor
ended up hooking a purplish monster this
new species
when denmark-based biologist yen ul
polson saw the first image
he was skeptical it's very grainy photo
almost like when you
uh when you see a photo of the loch ness
monster or something you kind of what is
this
there was no scale and when they told me
it was 25 kilos i just
i couldn't believe it the monster was
identified by japanese researchers as a
slick head
a fish named for its scale-free head but
most slickheads are only about a foot
long
this creature was the size and weight of
a small child
japanese scientists captured a rare
glimpse of the fish in motion
a switch of its tail suggesting a fast
powerful swimmer
it's kind of a mystery that finding this
fish was surprising but it's also a
mystery how could something
this large survive an environment that's
so hostile
it's not surprising to find big bony
fishes in surface layers of the ocean
but down that depth is a completely
different story
isotope analysis proved the fish dubbed
yokozuna or
sumo champ was an apex predator the deep
sea equivalent of a lion or
killer whale for marine biologists
japan's chance discovery in the
forbidding underwater canyon of saruga
bay
8 000 feet below the surface of the
ocean underscores how our
final frontier is right here on earth
there's a saying that we know much more
about the
the moon than the deep sea and it's very
true i mean we know
very little about the deep sea it's very
obvious this and this fish is a perfect
example of that statement
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo i always thought that was so
interesting and such a great point that
we know so little about the bottom of
the ocean
but no now we know about a lion but who
knew 90
right that dark about it unbelievable